[Music]
everybody close your eyes
um just kidding oh you can trust me i'm
just kidding
uh now i want you to imagine
uh a prairie with some butterflies
oh i got allergies already dude what the
[ __ ]
i saw prairie dog coming out oh i just
saw your butthole
i'm picturing that scene in gladiator
and russell crowley oh he's like
touching the weeds about to go to heaven
oh yeah that's kind of sad what do you
guys smell he's gonna see his family
now i see wheat i smell wheat now you
smell weak
change it man prairie he said
butterflies okay
allergies
we're sneezing now oh no uh what do you
hear
[ __ ] birds church the wrestling of
the leaves
oh the bugs are nice oh so we see bugs
now in birds i hear a motorcycle
motorcycle did we see the motorcycle too
no it's my friend
there's no roads in mine your friend
there probably
all right so but we see a visual right
yeah
we see a visual it's clearly a prairie
some nature kind
not really okay you don't really see it
why not i don't know i i think because
i'm hearing everyone speak so i'm just
like
hearing the words but i'm not
necessarily seeing an image we're at a
picnic together geo we're all on a
picnic
okay i see the picnic you see the picnic
yeah
yeah
what color is the uh the blanket mexican
color
oh it's like oh no i mean you know those
mexican blankets
kind of like dante southwestern oh south
west
yeah the pancho material one
yeah the correct on your eyes open your
eyes
i really like that material what is that
oh it's called it's like burlap
it's like canvas yeah it's like canvas
yeah it looks rough but it's actually
not that
it is rough to start with you gotta wash
it a few times it's still rough
it gets soft a little bit but you know
what it's really good for if your car's
interior is all [ __ ] up you cover your
seats in that [ __ ]
and it's very multi-colored yeah the
beach
blanket that corona poncho though corona
poncho you know the chrono one
yeah it was the cheap one but you bought
it i don't know they had corona beer on
it it was
oh yeah it was corona beer it was like
in ponchos that we had that was like
cheapos they were always
sponsored by corona i was talking about
corona the other day like the beer
company and i didn't mention
growing up beer and everyone looked at
me like i was crazy like what are you
talking about
like there were fighting words or
something beer must be hurt all right
anyway so
i have you guys uh imagining a
description a scene uh something for you
guys to visualize in your heads
now can you imagine a life where you
couldn't
do that well you just can't imagine
any images in your life you don't have
an imagination
like no pictures no pictures in
particular
like you have you have memory i know
that there's people that do that though
like that you know how we it's like some
people think in pictures some people
don't think in pictures
yeah and it's called they don't think in
pictures
yeah they don't see it what are you
thinking pictures it sounds like it
i'm thinking all kinds of [ __ ] i don't
know how we think i i teleported bro
you tell her you were there i was there
felt it dealt it yeah
it's either pictures words or feelings
that's how you can think
i think mine's all of them yeah yeah
some people in the hard drive
you're talking about in the hard drive
in the brain yeah
we are downloading what illegal movies
yes words what do you download i don't
even know i never i never think of it
like that i don't know
smell smell for sure i don't think i
don't know if i see like i guess i see
pictures obviously i was seeing a
picture but when you were in
when you were at neverland dude didn't
you guys
pretend you imagined imagination you
guys did a good job
you need to go back man i know you're
getting too old bro
i i see leaving neverland aged you man
i know we need a little more time not
really not really no not really
because he was there for like 300 years
you know
he still looks [ __ ] good i know but
when he came to the real world
like yeah but yeah so we're talking
about a thing called
advantage and advantage is the magic
it sounds pretty that should be like a
rapper or a singer
or you can name your day but hey this is
my baby advantage how come everything
with like
some kind of memory or brain loss is
cool like amnesia
yeah they call it really nice name
concussion
no you don't like that okay concussion i
like it
concussion a little concussion sounds
scary
but yeah so aphantasia is a medical
condition where people can't
uh imagine or visualize things in their
head
is it a condition or is it just it is
what it is
kind of like when like are you one where
it's like we're we're all born to like
we're not all born but
like the majority in this room can see
pictures right yeah because it's just
it is what it is that's how we're born
is that a condition something that
you know they're missing something or or
they had an accident that that happens
or it's just one of those that it is
what do they see how do they see that
they don't have it they do say 2.5
of the world's population have this
condition oh that's where they literally
can't remember or or conjure up an image
in their head when they're thinking of a
memory
so for example a guy he didn't he didn't
know he had
what uh aphantasia until his
when he was a kid his dad told him to go
to sleep he couldn't go to sleep so his
dad was like
well why don't you try counting sheep
and then
the kid as a kid he was like he stood he
he sat up in his own bed and he just
looked at the wall and was like
literally
doing the emotion of counting sheep
but he couldn't really imagine in his
own head like most people would just oh
okay lay down
close your eyes and you just imagine a
sheep and you count them
but he was like i don't know what that
means so he was like i'm gonna just
count sheep and stare at the wall doing
that what
and he realized he can't imagine what
sheep look like in his own head
but can't imagine nothing he can't he
can't see it imagine that
he's like i can't his name is what's it
called
uh aphantasia if this guy lost his keys
he's
[ __ ] your first go-to is like okay
retrace my steps yeah
open the door this was like oh
you can't how can you not imagine stuff
you can't even can't retrace his steps
or nothing
then well he
uses his memory and he can like he can
verbally memory yeah he has memories
that this is the the tricky part like i
was trying to understand what the
difference is memories and [ __ ] pages
so for example like in in the interview
that he was in he was saying how like oh
oh i know my
my wife just got uh her hair done so her
hair's up in a bun
and she was wearing a a red dress so you
can
he can actually remember it but he
doesn't have an image to go along with
it
if that makes sense maybe it's a word
maybe it's the word it does make sense
it makes sense
it makes sense how does that make sense
is that i'm like i can't do that without
seeing the image in my head so i guess
when i'm like you know when someone
describes something to you right let's
say joe goes like dude i just saw this
truck it was red it's dope
um i see a red truck yeah but that's my
red truck right that's different from
his red truck
so i think that's how this guy remembers
he remembers the characteristics and
like the adjective of the things
but not the exact thing that he saw yeah
i remember like things that happened but
i don't remember what people were
wearing that day
or like i might remember an event or an
action
or whatever but it's like instead of
maybe i pictured a blue shirt but then
it's like well i was wearing a gray
shirt that day
oh true true right right yeah no another
person actually realized he
uh had aphantasia whenever he was in
college
he went to a party and him and his
girlfriend
saw a mutual friend and now they're
coming back from the party
they're like oh it's nice seeing that
friend and they're like and then the
wife or the girlfriend said
yeah it was interesting that she ended
up wearing the exact same thing from
last year when we last saw her
to this party and then that guy was like
how would you know that
and she was like oh i think that i
remember it i pictured that i can
remember it and he was like that's also
crazy though to remember something that
happened a year unless it was like an
extra like she's wearing a [ __ ] fish
or something you know i would have been
a really really pretty dress or it could
be pretty dry i mean i remember
i remember clothing pretty good and me
too yeah from a year ago
what was your wearing last time last
time you were here i don't know
hold on a second i do remember i think
you're wearing a white hoodie i don't
know why hoodie oh no no no
wait so you're telling me this guy
doesn't have a spank bank either that's
what i was thinking oh my god
when when he's jerking off that night he
doesn't think of any visuals
no he just has to he has to watch it
because guys are so busy she keeps you
in the moment though huh keeps you in
the moment you can't
yeah yeah i remember being younger and
then
um like you know we didn't have like you
know
so much access to porn right so like
when you saw the playboy you go all
right try to [ __ ]
print it in my mind i'm trying to
remember so when i go home
i gotta [ __ ] imagine it and then you
go oh what did the [ __ ] look like again
i don't remember what it looks like
it was a very interesting time back in
those days with porn because it was like
we had playboy
any guy if you went to any guys
victoria's secret you guys always had
that too
like you go into someone's even a
stranger's house but you you know you
see the guy the house and
like you're in the bathroom you use the
bathroom like this this dude definitely
got a playboy in this bathroom yeah you
it occurs to you somewhere like taking a
piss or something
and then you're like taking it like that
a few minutes like you're like
in the shells like look at that and then
you check it out why did i do that
you put that [ __ ] you put that [ __ ] back
in exactly this place
why did dads always hide it under the
sink always out of the city
always dude and then it's someone in the
comments if one of the homies got
porn in the crew then is like we all got
a piece a video tape we're like yeah we
passed it around like passing around
yeah
now the kids got too much porn the kids
got porn
it's too much poor it's too much it's
pouring on their cell phones and their
ipads
do you think there's something uh unique
to sharing porn
and knowing that we all watch the same
[ __ ] versus like nowadays i think kids
are more likely to be more
they're more bonded if you jack off to
the same [ __ ] yeah right
because wouldn't you guys even watch
them together those porn stars are
bona fide porn stars and the new porn
stars i don't know if they're real stars
nah they ain't stars stain stars
[Laughter]
it's too real now it's too real yeah
it's too personal
this advantage you know you you think
you hear it and then you like try to
think do i got that
well you could picture [ __ ] right i
guess i can't believe you were earlier
saying you're straight right here
yeah right right i know but sometimes
you just think do i got that
or do i know someone that got that ant
how would you be an actor
if you had adaptations i don't know you
would be when you do object workers
you'd be in the moment
you might be not me you might not have
good sense of memory but you can like
how do you have thrust yourself in the
moment to just do it
what if what if it's the opposite of
this but you create so much in your mind
that you forget which one is real and
which one's fake
it's called uh it's a friend
which is also very pleasant sounding
nate i know right yeah name your
daughter
it sounds like a flower i sound like a
dj
[Laughter]
yeah what is that latin base for
probably something about like
[Laughter]
[Music]
you